dans le département du gers on ne compte
plus le nombre de terrains inondés par
les nombreux cours d'eau
si la plupart des habitations et
épargner les agriculteurs ne peuvent pas
en dire autant de leurs champs donc si
on va prendre à peu près 35 30
centimètres d'eau
c'est le cas de vincent rigaud
agriculteurs à virazeil
comme chaque année les ruisseaux qui
borde séchant déborde à chaque grosse
pluie on nous avons subi une inondation
suite aux derniers épisodes pluvieux
nous avons publié une pure mettrie de 60
70 mm ce qui n'est pas rare mais nous
avons subi une grosse inondation du fait
du mauvais entretien des cours d'eau
nous nous faut ces noms ruisseaux ont
débordé comme en deux ans ça fait quand
même quinze fois que ce ruisseau déborde
et pas pour des pluies excessives depuis
la loi jemmapes y entrer en vigueur le
1er janvier 2018
les élus locaux ont la charge de
l'entretien des cours d'eau qui relèvent
du domaine public
lorsque le cours d'eau passe par un
domaine privé
c'est le propriétaire lui-même qui doit
opérer l'entretien une tâche surveillé
par le fbi
l'office français de la biodiversité un
contrôle jugé par les agriculteurs
beaucoup trop sévère c'est un problème
qui est un récurrent qui est national
les cours d'eau ne sont plus entretenues
les lots les fossés inondé les parcelles
à cause d'une interdiction que l'ona de
faux car dès les fossés et de curer les
fossés et les petits cours d'eau
on n'a plus droit de toucher à ces cours
d'eau donc c'est devenu catastrophique
on a des inondations à répétition
s'il le fait s'il faut 40 aussi cure
s'il pose de drains il risque d forte
amende et de la prison de sursis l'année
dernière au printemps vincent rigaud a
vu ce même champ inondé
pour l'exploitant cette inondation a
entraîné la perte de sa récolte avec un
manque à gagner de plusieurs milliers
d'euros
le jour où il y aura l'importation de
maïs si ça déborde mais je perds je
perds toute ma culture la situation de
ces gras depuis vingt ans mais
s'accentue maintenant depuis depuis 4 5
ans ou vraiment nous faut c'est le cours
d'eau sont obstruées par le manque
d'entretien
il va falloir agir pourquoi arrêter ce
phénomène et cette catastrophe mais
maintenant ça suffit on va agir que la
police de l'eau ne soit d'accord ou pas
on agira conséquence directe de cette
loi les fossés ne sont plus entretenues
l'eau ne circulent plus et déborde la
moindre pluie pour combler les résultats
d'une loi peu ou pas comprises
un plan d'action national en matière de
gestion des risques des catastrophes
naturelles sera à l'ordre du jour du
prochain conseil des ministres